pues en este vídeo lo que quiero ver es
la anti derivada o la integral
indefinida de la función 1 / x
diferencial de x y bueno esto también lo
podemos escribir de la siguiente forma
la integral de x elevada a la menos 1 es
diferencial de x y de lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que si
usamos la regla de la potencia no
funciona porque nos quedaría x elevado a
la menos uno más uno que es cero entre
cero y no podemos dividir entre cero
entonces seguramente tú me vas a decir
pero yo recuerda una función llamada el
logaritmo natural de x que su derivada
era 1 / x por lo tanto si usamos la
lógica de la anti derivada esto me
quedaría que es el logaritmo natural de
x más una constante de integración y ya
acabamos para que ver tanto vídeo pero
hay que tener cuidado porque aunque no
es una respuesta incorrecta y no estaría
mal es una respuesta incompleta estas
dos funciones no son iguales porque los
dominios de estas dos funciones no son
iguales para esta función su dominio es
son todos los números reales excepto
cuando x vale 0 aquí la única
restricción es que x no valga 0 miente
aquí está definida la función logaritmo
natural para todas las x que sean
positivas o de otra manera para las x
que son mayores que 0 la verdad estaría
genial que la derivada es la solución
tuvieran el mismo dominio y si fuera así
lograríamos que esto fuese una igualdad
por lo tanto se me ocurre proponer a una
función la cual sea solución a mí se me
ocurre decir que si el logaritmo natural
de x está definido para los números
positivos entonces por qué no tomamos el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x por lo tanto esa base de mi propuesta
será ésta la solución entonces el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x y bueno esta es mi pregunta será ésta
la anti derivada de la función uno entre
x y para esto lo que hice fue dibujar la
gráfica por lo tanto lo mejor es que
hagamos la gráfica pac
y ha aparecido la gráfica y bueno yo sé
que no se hacen a la gráfica pero por
cuestiones de tiempo voy a poner la
gráfica aquí que ya tenía hecha del
logaritmo natural de x está la gráfica
que ya conocíamos del logaritmo natural
ahora cómo se va a ver la gráfica del
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x bueno para la parte positiva se va a
ver exactamente igual va a ser esto y
todo esto de aquí se va a ver
exactamente igual porque cuando x tome
valores positivos entonces esta función
va a ser la misma que el logaritmo
natural de mientras que cuando es
negativo
lo que pasa es supongamos en menos 1 si
pongo menos 1 me va a quedar el valor
absoluto de menos uno que es uno y el
logaritmo natural de uno que es cero y
por lo tanto me va a quedar lo mismo que
aquí a la derecha y si seguimos poniendo
y sustituyendo números vamos a encontrar
que la gráfica es exactamente la misma
que la derecha solamente que abre esta
vez hacia la izquierda son funciones
simétricas entonces intentemos dibujar
lo voy a intentar dibujar lo más
simétrico posible y me va a quedar algo
como esto que estoy dibujando ándale
creo que no me quedo tan mal y esta va a
ser la gráfica de y es igual al
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x esta de rosa es la gráfica de y es
igual al logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de xy ojo ten en cuenta que son
las dos curvas tanto en la curva de la
derecha como la curva de la izquierda y
ahora primeramente en lo que me voy a
fijar es que es lo que pasa cuando x es
mayor que 0 y lo voy a escribir aquí
cuando x es mayor que 0 pasa lo
siguiente bueno lo que va a pasar es que
el logaritmo natural del valor absoluto
de x va a ser exactamente igual al
logaritmo natural de x de x que estoy
poniendo no no no el logaritmo natural
de x ac caso y bueno entonces si x es
mayor que 0 lo que va a pasar es que la
derivada con respecto a x del logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de x pues va
a ser igual a la derivada con respecto a
x del logaritmo natural de x que por
cierto ya sabemos que esto es lo mismo
1 / x la función 1 / x recuerden que
todo esto pasa cuando x es mayor que 0 y
ahora voy a dibujar la función 1 / x
para que me quede también aquí en esta
misma gráfica va a ser la función que
está de color verde y es algo así mira
que no me quedan tan mal las gráficas
creo que tengo buen pulso y bueno esta
gráfica es así y después sigue así al
cruzar sigue decreciendo y que creen
está es la pendiente de la recta
tangente cuando x es mayor que 0 claro
de la función logaritmo natural de x por
ejemplo en este caso la pendiente de la
recta tangente tendría que valer 1 y en
la gráfica 1 entre x vale 1 o por
ejemplo veamos otro caso cuando la x
está muy pegada a cero que creen que es
lo que pase pues claro las pendientes
van a ser muy grandes y por lo tanto mi
función 1 / x también toma valores muy
grandes y de hecho va creciendo esta
función va creciendo esta función y por
lo tanto esta función va decreciendo la
pendiente cada vez es menor llega a cero
y vale 1
después de 1 las pendientes la recta
tangente van decreciendo y se nota
claramente en la curva 1 entre equis y
bueno ahora qué va a pasar del otro lado
de esta gráfica si nos fijamos en la
gráfica cuando x es menor que cero de lo
que nos vamos a dar cuenta que si
nosotros tenemos la pendiente de mi
recta tangente aquí va a ser la misma
que acá solamente que negativa es decir
la pendiente en efecto tangente en este
punto tiene el mismo valor que la
pendiente de mi recta tangente en este
punto solamente que con signo negativo y
si podemos observar eso entonces nos
vamos a dar cuenta que la gráfica de la
derivada se va a tener que ver de la
siguiente manera para valores donde la x
tiende a menos infinito la pendiente de
la recta tangente que muestra la gráfica
del logaritmo natural del valor absoluto
de x son muy cercanos a 0 y por lo tanto
la gráfica de la derivada va a estar
pegado a 0 para el logaritmo natural del
valor absoluto de menos 1 la derivada
vale menos 1 y después cuando la gráfica
del logaritmo natural del valor absoluto
de x se acerca a 0 las pendientes de la
recta tangente empiezan a decrecer
demanda
drástica y por lo tanto la gráfica de la
derivada debe atender a menos infinito y
se debe de ver algo así y para que estoy
contando esto a bueno porque si nosotros
hacemos la idea intuitiva podemos ver y
aunque no lo he probado rigurosamente
que entonces la derivada del lugar y
natural del valor absoluto de x pues es
este la función que tienen los valores
de las pendientes de la recta tangente
que nosotros queremos y vamos a apuntar
lo la derivada con respecto a x del
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x es uno entre x ojo para todas x que
sea distinta de cero es decir para todas
las x que sean mayores que 0 y para
todas las x que sean menores que 0 se
cumple esta igualdad y es justo lo que
queríamos y con todo esto estoy
enseñándoles que tienen los mismos
dominios y eso era muy importante y
aunque tal vez ésta no sea la prueba más
fidedigna matemáticamente hablando de
manera gráfica lo que quería es que se
dieran cuenta de la interposición era
necesario fijarnos en los dominios y
ahora sí ya puedo concluir que la
integral de 1 / x
el dx es el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de x más una constante de
integración